you and human rights folks Minh says
this morning quote you cannot dismiss
entire countries and continents it
legitimizes the targeting of people
based on who they are Debora patta is in
Johannesburg where many South Africans
say they feel like targets of the
President of the United States
Deborah good morning good morning from
South Africa which has been renamed
salsa expletive hole by this country's
most famous export Daily Show host
Trevor Noah
Africans aren't taking too kindly to
president Trump's comments the
spokesperson for the African Union
Commission uber-cool Ando said that
given the historical reality where many
Africans arrived in the US during the
Atlantic slave trade this flies in the
face of all accepted behavior and
practice and the leader of South
Africa's official opposition moussey
mamani
tweeted that President Trump is
promoting a racist agenda u.s. Africa
relations will take strain from this
from a leader who has failed to
reconcile humanity Africans are often
quick to criticize their leaders but woe
betide anyone who insults at this
continent and for the most part Africans
responded with humor morning breakfast
shows began with comments like welcome
to my expletive hole and some people
posted gorgeous pictures of Africa on
social media with comments like a
beautiful sunset from my experiment REE
Nora oh my well Debora patta and
Johannesburg thank you so much